[Música]
todos
no vivamos simplemente una vida
diseñamos una mesa con la que siempre
hemos soñado les he traído un regalo es
una piedra una simple piedra pero una
piedra la cual ustedes le van a dar el
significado el significado de esa piedra
es el que van a descubrir hoy y es
porque están a punto de empezar a
diseñar la vida que sueña así se llama
el mensaje que yo les vengo a traer
diseña la vida que sueñas
tres piedras forman una pared esta es la
historia de la piedra eric lines es un
reconocido arqueólogo de nuestros
tiempos y eric klein nos cuenta que de
un de una de una excavación es posible
que solo se encuentren tres piedras que
alguna vez fueron parte de una pared
tres piedras que alguna vez fueron parte
de algo mucho más grande y es el trabajo
de los arqueólogos descubrir cuál es la
historia que esas tres piedras cuentan
cuál es esa pared que construye cuando
alguien cuando ustedes ya no estén y
alguien encuentre encuentre esa piedra
que yo les acabo de dar cuál es este
mensaje cuál es esa historia que esa
persona va a reconstruir de ustedes
cuál es esa historia que esa piedra va a
contar cuando ustedes ya no estén para
contarla entonces eso es lo que vamos a
hacer hoy
esta historia comienza hace 20 años
cuando yo estaba en la entrega de notas
finales del colegio las monjitas
decidieron llevar un conferencista para
que hablara acerca del proyecto de vida
él empezó su historia contándonos un
breve cuento y nos dijo imagínense a
ustedes que en este momento toman un
taxi y se suben y el taxista les
pregunta buenas noches usted para dónde
va y ustedes le contestan a no sé no sé
para dónde usted me lleve que les
responde el taxista
vaya sí si usted no sabe para dónde va
pues yo para donde me lo voy a llevar o
muéstrame de pronto la billetera a ver
si de pronto sabemos hacer un negocio
entonces no se trata del vehículo que
nosotros tomemos para diseñar la vida
que nosotros soñamos pueden ser nuestros
pies puede ser una silla de ruedas puede
ser un mercedes o pueda que no sea ese
lo importante es que sepamos para dónde
vamos no importan las circunstancias de
nuestras vidas cuando nosotros tenemos
un propósito claro y eso fue lo que me
pasó después de esta charla el es jorge
duque linares muy reconocido en todo es
una autoridad en términos de proyecto de
vida después de esta charla y después de
ese pedacito de la charla
yo dije papi por favor cómprame el libro
y mi papá me compro el libro y yo me lo
leí y durante cinco años seguí esos
pasos que el libro proponía yo hacía mi
lista un check list anual de tareas que
iba cumpliendo a medida que el tiempo
iba pasando
pero llegó un momento cuando salí de la
universidad donde ya no encontraba tanto
sentido a lo que estaba haciendo y me
hice una pregunta y es la pregunta que
les voy a hacer en este momento de
ustedes
cuando escuchen cinco por cinco veces el
sonido de este instrumento ya han tenido
que contestar la pregunta y esa pregunta
que yo me hice fue
cuál es mi propósito
lo tiene
levante la mano el que contestó ser
feliz
bueno ser feliz es un muy noble
propósito y muy personal pero el
propósito siempre sin excepción alguna
incluye a otras personas
si no incluye a otros es una meta es
tuya ser feliz puede ser una meta pero
no es un propósito el propósito trae
consigo la felicidad pero también trae
obstáculos que nosotros debemos ir
enfrentando y debemos ir pasando esto
entonces dónde está el problema el
problema es buscar afuera de nosotros el
significado de nuestras vidas y de
nuestra existencia es hacernos la
pregunta de la forma incorrecta de
afuera hacia adentro y no de adentro
hacia afuera cuáles son mis habilidades
que tengo yo para dar cuál es mi
propuesta de valor dónde puedo yo
aportar a otros a quién puedo ayudar
cómo lo puedo ayudar realmente yo que sé
y qué puedo enseñar
y esto nos lleva a que tenemos que
trabajar en tres elementos principales
para ir descubriendo nuestro propósito
primero método segundo disciplina y
tercero determinación los dos últimos
son transversales al método y siempre
están presentes podemos tener el mejor
método del mundo pero si no existe la
disciplina y no está la determinación no
vamos a conseguir nuestro propósito
desde mi trabajo en innovación
he descubierto que podemos llevar el
potencial que tienen las empresas para
crear diferentes modelos de negocio a
nuestras propias vidas y no solamente
una vida el método tradicional nos dice
que nosotros los seres humanos que
estamos acostumbrados a pensar de forma
lineal tenemos una idea la ejecutamos la
llevamos a cabo y si falla el fracasado
y eso nos pasa con la vida crecemos
estudiamos una carrera que sea más o
menos afín con nuestra personalidad nos
lanzamos a hacer la especialización
maestría doctorado posgrado y todo lo
demás que quieran hacer y si algo
fracasa si no consigo el trabajo de mis
sueños entonces habré fracasado en la
vida y muchas personas no logran salir
de ahí y eso es lo que tiene ricos a los
psicólogos de américa latina como dice
checho
entonces qué es el método trabajando en
las empresas y trabajando en mis
proyectos personales en más de siete y
de siete experimentos hechos por mí
digamos que fueron emprendimientos
fallidos conocí a alexander osterwalder
la vida me llevó allí a su tesis de
grado todavía el libro no existía y él
me lo compartió
y empezamos una conversación acerca de
los modelos de negocio cruz el océano
fui hasta viena me certifique modelos de
negocio
y después a través de alexander conocí a
tim clark entonces estimo que hizo cogió
los modelos de negocios empresariales y
los volvió personales para mostrarnos
cómo podemos tener una propuesta de
valor igual que las empresas que es la
propuesta de valor es la forma como las
empresas crean y generan valor para
entregárselo a otros pero nosotros somos
también empresas yo soy una empresa y yo
también tengo que crear mi propuesta de
valor para entregársela a otro y que
esté dispuesto a pagar por ella
y luego
me hice experta en design thinking y eso
me tiene hoy en el trabajo en el que
estoy
pero yo dije algo falta hace falta el
propósito porque cuando yo decidí
empezar a desarrollar estos modelos algo
me hacía falta y me hacía falta el
propósito y por eso creé mi segundo
regalo para ustedes
el canvas de la vida el canvas de la
vida es una herramienta que tiene nueve
bloques nueve bloques que nos invitan a
reflexionar acerca de diferentes
aspectos de nuestras vidas la carrera
profesional lo material lo social la
vida personal la salud mental la física
lo espiritual el altruismo los
sentimientos el amor los costos y las
deudas y los ingresos que nos dice el
canvas esto debería estar en equilibrio
si yo logro un equilibrio en estas nueve
facetas de mi vida estaré en un punto de
satisfacción donde cualquier cosa que yo
haga puede ir a un nivel superior
pero en este canvas no viene solo este
canvas viene acompañado de otras
herramientas que también crean el canvas
del propósito entonces a mí siempre me
preguntan bueno pero como descubrió cuál
es mi propósito sencillo quién soy yo
qué tengo para dar cuáles son mis
talentos cuáles son mis habilidades qué
personalidad acompaña esos talentos y
esas habilidades es importante
reconocerlo porque si yo soy muy
introvertido y quiero ser vendedor pues
entonces me toca fortalecerla para yo
poder llegar a tener una venta cerrarla
con éxito a quien ayudó a las personas
oa las empresas cuál es la definición de
mi propósito y luego está el canvas de
la vida futura
este canvas de la línea futura ha hecho
llorar a muchas personas en los talleres
y yo les pregunto bueno pero por qué
lloras y vienen y me dicen por qué es
que me voy a morir y sí porque yo lo que
les digo es este es hoy y allá el día de
su muerte
y qué va a pasar de hoy el día que usted
se muera cuál es ese legado que va a
dejar y la gente empieza a llorar porque
hay muchas personas que a los 50 años
están empezando a mirar que hacen de sus
vidas a los 50 años se están
reinventando pero bueno hay que tener
valentía para uno de los 50 años
reinventarse pero en la cuenta que hacen
es la siguiente yo ya viví más de la
mitad de mi vida
y entonces empiezan a llorar no no se
trata de llorar se trata de ser
realistas la vida se nos acaba y todos
los días nos metemos en una lucha y un
conflicto y creemos que la vida no se
acaba pero la vida es tan frágil que se
puede acabar incluso el día que yo
llegue la primera línea de mi vida
como logramos entonces tener varias
vidas en una sola vida utilizando la
metodología de las empresas diferentes
modelos para una sola vida diferentes
modelos para una sola empresa la
aerolínea en la que yo trabajo tiene
tres modelos por lo menos bien
identificados y diferentes el primero el
transporte de personas que les da
visibilidad marca el segundo el
transporte de carga que les da
rentabilidad y el tercero
el tercer el tercer modelo de negocio es
consultorías entrenamientos a otros
pilotos mantenimiento y ese modelo de
negocio que le da una base para
mantenerse en las personas cómo funciona
yo soy empleada tengo un ingreso estable
pero además soy escritora y eso me da
visibilidad me permite comunicarme con
las personas y contar historias y no
escribo solo sobre esto escribo novelas
novelas de amor me encanta entonces yo
ahí desahogo toda esa creatividad que
tengo y me conecto con el amor y soy
consultora y eso me da satisfacción
personal
como logramos esto tengo dos personas en
mi equipo de trabajo
que son un muy buen ejemplo para traer
hoy acá uno de ellos es antropólogo y él
sufre de ansiedad social es una persona
muy introvertida las personas dentro de
mi equipo de trabajo tienen que tener un
propósito y es uno de sus cafés nadie
más dentro de la aerolínea evalúa esto
en sus equipos de trabajo todos ellos
tienen 5% de su salario depende de tener
un modelo de negocio personal tienen que
tener empresa tienen que salir a
emprender así fracasen pero tienen que
tener la motivación por fuera del
trabajo y adivinen por qué por qué es
que el trabajo nunca nos hace 100%
felices siempre estamos diciendo ahí es
que yo estoy aburrido es que yo me
quiero ir es que está meca de gorda la
jefa no me quiere no sé qué y siempre
nos queremos ir y como le quito yo eso a
mi equipo de trabajo como le quito ese
peso entonces vaya y piense en lo que le
gusta
louis
en medio de su introversión él descubrió
que a través de los juegos él podría
llegar a conectarse con las personas
introvertidas y enseñar a las
organizaciones y al mundo que está
diseñado sólo para los extrovertidos a
lidiar con personas como él y enseñar a
las personas que no se puede que no
tienen un contacto social fluido a poder
ser como él a poder enfrentar esa
introversión entonces decidió crear un
juego y unas aplicaciones para ayudar a
personas y organizaciones a enfrentar la
introversión y karen llegó con una idea
ya más o menos demasiada acerca de hacer
artículos de moda con productos
reciclados
cuando ya llegó con su idea ya había
hecho un montón de billeteras un montón
de bolsos le dije bueno bye los vendes
bay los vendes y después hablamos y
regreso con sus billeteras y sus bolsos
y algunos bien remendados porque nos
sirvieran y bueno qué pasó no pues la
verdad no funcionaron y no sé qué y yo
bueno
tú para que eres buena
para organizar a mí la gente me gusta
para organizar y yo organizo los cajones
de mi casa y yo organizo los papeles y
organizo esto y yo le dije cómo puedes
llevar lo sostenible a la organización y
en este momento se está planteando un
proyecto que es una caneca inteligente
que le da puntos a las personas que la
utilicen para que sepan cómo cómo
seleccionar los desechos que producen y
que las empresas puedan entregar puntos
para esas personas que están haciendo
bien su trabajo sostenible interesante
no así es como podemos llevar los
modelos de negocios de las empresas a
nuestra vida personal pero bueno y eso
como es listo esto tiene el método
siempre tiene unos pasos primer paso
quién soy yo cuál es cuál es mi
personalidad cuál es ese canvas del
propósito que yo tengo cuáles son mis
habilidades y después entendiendo mi
vida bueno voy a calificar todas las
fases de mi vida de 1 a 5 a ver dónde
estoy porque yo necesito visualizar
claramente dónde me siento bien y dónde
no estoy también
diseñando mi vida tres modelos de
negocio personal a mí no vengan a decir
es que yo soy abogado y voy a ser
abogado toda mi vida y hasta el día que
me muera no usted puede ser abogado pero
también puede ser panadero yo cocino mi
mamá es chef y yo también cocino y
también experimenté por ahí y fracasé y
el día que me pegue un quemón acá y me
queda una cicatriz por un buen tiempo yo
no quería que la cicatriz se fuera
porque el día que a mí me quedó esa
cicatriz yo dije saben que esta cicatriz
es el recuerdo de que a mí me gusta la
cocina pero para compartir con mis
amigos no para vendérselo a los demás y
ahí se reme local y me fui a trabajar a
otra a una empresa de tecnología luego
planear cómo planeó mi vida pues donde
estoy hoy y dónde me quiero morir y
después probar ese es el design thinking
el design thinking es un modelo que nos
dice prueba
crea hipótesis sobre tu vida y qué
pasaría si este talento que yo tengo tan
bueno de bailar entonces monté una
academia y qué pasaría así a parte de
ser psicólogo entonces también soy
comediante y qué pasaría si ese es el
design thinking probarlo
recuerden que habíamos hablado que
teníamos otros otros dos elementos la
disciplina y la determinación la
disciplina es aquello que me mueve en
esos días donde no quiero saber de nada
ni de nadie ni siquiera de mi propósito
y la disciplina tiene cuatro pasos que
debemos tener muy claros primero mis
habilidades segundo tener un plan de
acción claro tercero poner en marcha el
plan de acción y cuarto tener un plan b
porque es que si el plan falla tengo que
tener un plan b porque si no estoy
fallando el design thinking que me
invita a probar y experimentar y la
determinación la determinación no es más
que tener conciencia y responsabilidad
sobre el resultado de mis actos si
señores la determinación no es ay si lo
quiere hacer lo voy a hacer si no la
determinación es si yo decidí escribir
la novela pues me atengo a las
consecuencias son dos años sentadas sin
inspiración tratando de que me llegue la
inspiración de algún lado y la voy a
terminar y fueron dos años y ya está
está próxima a salir la otra y está en
camino unos cuentos mujeres entonces
señores ustedes son los que diseñan son
los que construyen y cómo les gustaría
pasar el resto de sus vidas conserven la
piedra como un regalo que les quiero
dejar el cual tiene significado solo si
ustedes se los dan muchas gracias
i
[Música]
y